[Musik]
Eure Heiligkeit Ich begrüße euch herzlich in
unserem Programm es ist mir eine Ehre euch
bei uns zu haben danke red wanna call me oz
ihr seid ein unermüdlicher Förderer des Dialogs
nicht nur des Dialogs zwischen den Religionen
sondern auch des Dialogs zwischen
Politikwissenschaft und Spiritualität selbst I  arbeite
seit 20 Jahren als Muslimin im interreligiösen Dialog, und es gibt
eine bestimmte Frage, die
häufig in unseren Reden aufgeworfen wurde oder wenn Sie
Reden halten oder Menschen, die Ihre Bücher lesen,
bereits offen für den Dialog sind, aber
wie erreichen Sie all diese Menschen?  Menschen,
die nicht zum Dialog bereit oder nicht bereit sind,
weil wir dieselben Menschen sind, sehen Sie,
wir haben die Fähigkeit zum Denken, und wir alle
haben die Fähigkeit, ganzheitlicher zu wirken,
und nicht nur kurzfristig, sondern
langfristig interessiert,
also sehen Sie normalerweise, dass die Leute
besonders sagen  Wenn sich Emotionen entwickeln,
nutzen Sie unsere Fähigkeit, die
Realität besser zu kennen, nicht, da wir normalerweise
nicht sehen, wie dieses Potenzial genutzt wird, nur
kurzsichtig und unmittelbar  sawasdee
eine Art Befriedigung Sie sehen, dass Sie
andere kritisieren Hamada
oder wurden andere getötet Sie erhalten eine
Befriedigung
, die auf lange Sicht kurzsichtig ist Sehen Sie
niemandes Interesse, deshalb glaube ich, dass die
grundlegende menschliche Natur mitfühlender ist,
und wir haben diese wunderbare Brenda,
also durch Bildung durch Bewusstsein
Also die Leute, die nur Sie sehen,
denken, dass es etwas ist, das sich
ändern kann, sehen aus einer breiteren Perspektive und sehen
jedes Problem, wenn wir genau hinsehen,
erscheint es unerträglich, aber dasselbe Problem
aus der Ferne aus einer breiteren
Perspektive zu betrachten, und dann fühlen Sie sich oh okay
, das ist traurig, aber immer noch okay  Wenn Sie
auf die letzten Jahrzehnte zurückblicken, denken Sie, dass die
Menschen allgemein offener
für den Dialog geworden sind, oder sehen Sie, dass die
Menschen so weit kommen wie meine eigene Art von
Erfahrung, die ich jetzt glaube, der interreligiöse
Dienst, denke ich, unser letztes, ich denke, ein
Jahrzehnt zehn  Jahren ist eine viel Steigerung
wo ich immer wieder Gelegenheit in die
Glaubensbegegnung gehe und diese interreligiöse nicht
nur von sehr oberflächlichen Menschen  ernst,
also sage ich normalerweise, ich sage immer, getragen von
einer Quellenansicht oder glaube, dass alle wichtigen
Weltsituationen, von denen du sagst, dieselbe Botschaft haben, dieselbe
Praxis, Tanzpraxis oder Liebe, und mit
dieser Praxis der Toleranz, der Praxis der
Vergebung und der Surfindustrie, dann werden sie
in der Philosophie ein anderes
Konzept entwickeln  nicht, aber dann müssen wir
darüber nachdenken, was der Zweck dieser
verschiedenen Strömungen ist.
Derselbe Zweck, den Sie sehen, um eine feste
Überzeugung über den Wert der Liebe, des
Mitgefühls zu schaffen. Lassen Sie uns ein wenig zu
den verschiedenen Philosophien oder Praktiken gehen, zu denen
wir finden, dass der Buddhismus in Europa
geworden ist  Sehr attraktiv finden wir sogar
Unternehmen, die
buddhistische Weisheit und buddhistische Praxis zumindest bis zu einem gewissen Grad
anpassen. Was denken Sie
darüber, aber ISM im Allgemeinen Browns
durch den Osten, traditionell kommt der Buddhismus
aus dem Osten, so dass verschiedene Menschen eine
andere Art von religiösem Glauben haben, also im
Westen  Der Westen hat hauptsächlich die
jüdisch-christliche Tradition und in gewissem
Maße den Islam, daher ist es viel sicherer, sich daran zu
halten  Nes eigener religiöser
Glaube, seine wechselnde Religion, schafft manchmal
etwas Verwirrung, also ist es besser, das nicht so zu halten
,
aber unter den Millionen von Menschen
glauben einige nicht, glauben nicht leicht
an einen bestimmten Glauben, aber
gleichzeitig wollen sie eine Art von Spiritualität
oder irgendeine Art  der Geistesschulung, die
manche Leute verwenden, um Interesse zu zeigen, ja,
es war Buddhismus oder eine andere
Art alter indischer Tradition wie ein Jain-
Buddhismus und eine andere Art
hinduistischer Traditionen, so dass individuelles
Recht, aber dann wichtig ist, obwohl Sie
der Fall sind, dass dies individuell ist  eine neue
Religion,
wie Schwiegermütter, einige Hindus oder
Dschinn, effektiver,
geeigneter, aber das bedeutet nicht, dass Ihre
traditionelle Religion keinen Wert mehr hat,
daher muss diese Person ihren
traditionellen Glauben respektieren, sehr wichtig,
also wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe  skeptisch sind
gegenüber leuten die sagen sie sind
christlich buddhisten oder buddhistische
christen
ich halte das anfangs ja für möglich ho  w
Christlicher Kräuterkundler
, das bedeutet, dass Sie sehen, dass Sie den Schöpfer glauben, und
dies ist Jesus Christus oder die Dreieinigkeit.
Gleichzeitig sehen Sie auch den Respekt vor dem Glauben
, um das Richtige auf
dieser Ebene zu setzen. Ich denke, dass die Kombination
einiger Menschen ein Feld ist, das diese Art von
Einstellung mit sich bringt  mehr innerer Frieden,
angenehmer okay, aber dann erreichen Sie eine
tiefere Ebene als das buddhistische Konzept,
Sie sehen Leere, also gibt es bei diesem Konzept
keinen Raum für den unabhängigen
absoluten Schöpfer, also
denke ich, dass ich vor einiger Zeit mehr als zehn Jahre an meinem
sehr engen Freund gearbeitet habe  Freund, ein
christlicher Mönch aus einer amerikanischen Stadt, eine wunderbare Person, die
wir Ihnen anbieten, um die Körper unserer
Eckpraxis wie Mitgefühl,
Vergebung, Toleranz zu besprechen und auch zu sehen, wie
er Interesse zeigt und von der
indischen Tradition den einzigen Punkt der
Meditation lernen möchte, damit diese so weit verbreitet sind, wie wir
Diskutieren Sie dies frei,
dann fragte er mich einmal nach dem
Konzept der Leere, dann sagte ich, ich sagte,
ich sagte ihm, oder fragen Sie nicht, dass
oh, die Leere der Budd ist  sein
geschäft nicht christlich geschäft
willst du dieses konzept nicht teilen ja
das bin ich denn ich fürchte den hinteren
buddhisten ich meine das buddhistische konzept
einer davon für dieses
konzept existiert das nichts intimes unabhängig voneinander also
ist das nach dem buddhismus  und der
Jainismus und ein anderer alter Traditionssarkasmus
sehen kein Konzept des Schöpfers, also sehen Sie,
dass diese Art von saurer Sicht
vertraut wird, wie ich selbst, dass dieser Freund, den
er suchte, einsgerichteter Glaube war
, war Gott geschaffen, oder sagen Sie
die negative Wirkung, so ziehe ich es an  Ich möchte nicht, dass
es besser ist, seine eigene Tradition zu bewahren,
aber warum denkst du, dass der Buddhismus
für Europäer so attraktiv ist?
Der Glaube ist zwar Hingabe,
aber eine ziemlich gründliche Untersuchung und ein
Experiment, das Buddha feststellte,
so dass Sie in einer früheren Sanskrit-Tradition daher in einer früheren
Tradition ausgiebig
Geschichten verwenden  Logikforschung, dann das
Experiment, also diese Leute, die
wissenschaftlicher denken und Gründe lieben. Das
vorherige Buch nenne ich normalerweise den deutschen Papst.
Sie sehen, er hat es erwähnt
, der Grund muss zusammenpassen
die eine wissenschaftliche
Denkweise haben, die die Vernunft lieben, nicht leicht
akzeptieren, dass dies ein gewisser Dienst ist, Lee-Idee,
nur durch den Glauben, dann
denke ich, solche Leute, ich denke, vielleicht eine Anziehungskraft, es war eine
buddhistische Herangehensweise, nur die Vernunft zu nutzen
und zu experimentieren, lassen Sie uns jetzt bewegen -
und  dann einige mache ich den Rest
Lektion Westler sind die, die
Interesse am Buddhismus zeigen, einige verwenden eher
ich denke, wenn ich so sagen darf, ein bisschen
blindes Vertrauen Ich meine, nur die Praxis
ohne Argumentation, nur um zu behandeln, es gibt
nicht einige nicht nicht den Klang, den ich nicht sehe
Gut, lassen Sie uns zu einem anderen Thema übergehen, nämlich
den buddhistisch-islamischen Beziehungen.
Gibt es etwas, das derzeit im
buddhistisch-islamischen Dialog nicht in
großem Umfang, sondern wie in Lad stattfindet  akh
Nordindien Ich erzähle traditionell eine sehr enge
Beziehung zu Buddhisten und es ist ein Muslim.
Ja, also für einige habe
ich seit vielen Jahren sehr engen Kontakt zu
muslimischen Brüdern, Schwestern, die beide
Sunniten in der Unterlänge haben. Ich war
am selben Tag, als ich Ladakh zum ersten Mal als
Pilgerreise besuchte  zum buddhistischen Tempel dann als nächstes
bald
sunnitische Moschee dann Schermoschee am selben Tag am
selben Morgen Gottesdienst es ist Muslim
eine der wichtigsten Weltreligionen
jetzt Anhänger des Islam oder des Korans
nicht sehr wichtige Religion und viele
muslimische wunderbare Menschen wirklich wunderbare
einige schelmische Menschen darunter  Muslime,
sie gehören auch zu den Buddhisten, sie
gehören zu den Hindus, zu den Christen,
zu den Juden, überall einige
schelmische Leute, diese paar
Raketen, Leute, die nie gründlich
casada sind, repräsentieren die ganze Tradition, die wir
heutzutage unterscheiden müssen, um heute zu sehen,
er sieht normalerweise den Tag, wenn
etwas passiert  Es ist passiert, dass sie normalerweise Leute
sagen, muslimischer Terrorist oder irgendeine Gelegenheit, die in
Burma steckt  Terrorist, das ist absolut
falsch, also echte muslimische echte buddhistische
Nachbarn werden geduldet, anderen Menschen zu schaden.
Die Muslime laut muslimischem Islam
sagen, dass sie laut Koran sehen, dass jede Art
von muslimischen Islampraktizierenden
andere richtig respektieren muss, und wenn
Blutvergießen entsteht, ist die Realität nicht mehr echter
Islampraktizierender und das sehr  Bedeutung
und dann der muslimische Freund, wenn es mir
gesagt hat, der muslimische Praktizierende muss die
Liebe erweitern, die den Schöpfer Allahs betreten
die
Taliban den Buddha-Status im
Bamiyan-Tal in Afghanistan zerstörten, wie glauben Sie
, dass diese barbarischen Taten
die buddhistisch-islamischen Beziehungen zu
der Zeit geprägt haben, als einige Buddhisten dieses
Land probierten, sollten Sie mich fragen
, ob Sie tatsächlich sagen, wenn Sie mich kritisieren, ich
Schweigen über dieses Ereignis. Ich
fühlte, dass die Vergangenheit heute vorbei ist. In diesem Bereich gibt es
keinen Buddhisten, also einen Buddha  ue ist es nicht
sehr relevant für die Einheimischen. Ich habe
gehört, dass das bemerkenswert ist, also denke ich,
wenn Sie in die Geschichte eingehen. Ich denke, der Zerstörer
von Nylander Muslim am Boot
denke
viel schaden durch muslime also ist vergangenheit vorbei wenn
wir diese dinge wiederholen würden also kein wert
vergangenheit ist vorbei
nun lass uns zur gegenwart gehen und du hast
vorhin auch die situation in myanmar erwähnt wo wir
wissen das es so ist  Verfolgung der
muslimischen Minderheit der Leukämien und
der führenden Persönlichkeit Myanmars, dem Chefdiplomaten
Ich bin Sam su Qi, der auch wie Sie
Träger des Polizeinobelpreises ist
, von Muslimen beschuldigt wird, zu dem Problem zu schweigen, zu dem
Sie Stellung nehmen  Das
und das erste, also das Ereignis, das der buddhistische
Mönch einige heute summende muslimische Gemeinschaften nutzt,
dass, als diese Nachricht kam, ich in
Washington war, fragten mich einige Medienleute,
dann drücke ich aus oder sehr traurig, dann
sollten sich diese Buddhisten vorstellen, uns
das vor Augen zu führen  In dem Moment, in dem sie ein negatives Gefühl verspüren, stellen Sie sich
Buddhas
Gesicht vor, wenn Buddha dorthin kommt,
projizieren Sie definitiv diese muslimischen Brüder, Schwestern,
also ist es etwas sehr Trauriges, und
dann hatten sie tatsächlich
ein paar Mal ein
Treffen mit Sushi-Säure  von dem reißerischen, von
einigen Romanen bestellten Treffen und einer
, die in London kurz leuchtet, nehme ich an,
dass ich erwähnt habe, dass Sie
etwas tun sollten, dann sagt sie, eine sehr
komplizierte und eine Militärregierung, die
Sie sehen, haben einige Strafen für diese
Dinge, als ich von meiner Seite erschien  ihr,
aber sie findet einige Zeit einige Schwierigkeiten
und ich habe keine Verbindung zu Burmesen
zu Burma. Ich war noch nie dort.
Was uns hier in Europa erstaunt, durch
Ihre Heiligkeit,
Sie sind streng gewaltfrei, und was
wir sehen, dass sie von Mönchen kommen, ist
Gewalt,
also ist das erstaunlich  uns, weil
wir hier glauben, dass der Buddhismus das
Image hat, eine streng gewaltfreie
Religion zu sein, wie ich zuvor die mit
Mönchen erwähnt habe  's Robe o Gewalt eigentlich nicht
mehr buddhistisch
wie die Muslime zu sagen,
diejenigen, die Gewalt Terroristen nicht
mehr begehen Ich denke, Jenny Buddhist und
Jain Islam rechts zurück zu unserer
Gesellschaft hier sehen Sie diese Lehre, die nicht
auf so einer Gelegenheit in Mexiko basiert
Ich traf das, glaube ich, an
der Universität und sie luden mich ein. Ich ging
dorthin und viele Bischöfe dort, also sagte ich
ihnen, manchmal bleiben religiöse Menschen des Glaubens
auf unserer Kleidung, so lange sie sich
dort anziehen und diese heilige
Person der Stadt sehen, wenn sie sich heute anziehen  was hieß
Casa entfernen dann nicht mehr jenny
üben ja das ist
also ein fehler so viele bischöfe
sehen sie es gibt wirklich eine stadt stimmen zu oder sortieren sie
heute worte bitte hier so hier
diese art von kommentar so so religion es ist
mentale einstellung nicht physische art von
erscheinen  Buddhistische Mönche seilten sich ab, wenn sie
geistig und zum Töten und
Töten nicht mehr buddhistisch sind
, empfindet deine Heiligkeit jemals Wut, ja
gelegentlich, und wie begegnest du deiner Wut
r wie gehst du mit deiner wut um, du
kennst meine mitarbeiterin, wenn sie einen
kleinen fehler gemacht hat und ich schreie, aber
das denke ich, ein paar sekunden da
nichts, was ich sehe, wir haben über wut gesprochen,
lass uns reden, wir schreiben schon zum ende
aber  Lassen Sie uns über eine andere Angst sprechen
, die möglicherweise verärgern muss. Unsere Gesellschaft ist
heutzutage sehr von
Angstgefühlen und Ängsten geprägt. Wir empfinden besonders
die Angst, unsere kulturelle Identität
hier in Europa durch Einwanderung durch
Globalisierung zu verlieren. Was denken Sie darüber
, weil Sie haben?  die erfahrung
als flüchtling als jemand der im exil lebt
auf der gleichen seite deine leute
kämpfen für ihre kultur und religiöse
identität also eins zu eins hast du
beide perspektiven was sagst du den menschen
hier wenn sie angst haben ihre identität
so zu verlieren  Im Moment sage ich immer, da
die oben genannten Flüchtlinge aus einer
schrecklichen Gegend Afrikas kommen, schätze ich erstens
, dass der Erhalt dieser
Verweise ihnen wunderbar Schutz und
Erleichterung verschafft hat  vor allem die deutsche
Bundeskanzlerin, ich denke, sie ist wirklich
ich denke, sie zeigt menschliches Gefühl,
inzwischen habe ich von Anfang an
die Meinung und auch dementsprechend drücke ich aus
, dass die Europäische Union
diese mehreren tausend jetzt rund Millionen
Flüchtlinge aufnimmt, von denen sie sagen, dass sie ihnen Schutz bieten für
Bilder  der Schwierigkeiten sicher und dann
bieten zwei kleine Kinder eine Einrichtung für
Bildung, dann sollten junge Leute eine Ausbildung geben,
schließlich sollten Sie sehen, dass sie
sich in ihrem eigenen Heimatland registrieren
und ihr Zuhause wieder aufbauen sollten, und dann denke ich, dass
sie diejenigen
unserer Stadtnationen sind, die ihnen helfen,
Sie sehen es kontinuierlich  Hilfe, wenn sie
in ihr eigenes Land zurückkehren, Bereitstellung von
Einrichtungen, Missionen und einige in einigen Fällen
brauchen etwas Geld, in Ordnung,
ich sehe so lange, ja, ich habe es
bebaut, ganze Araber, ganze Araber, andere Leute, die
Sie sehen, können nicht hierher kommen und arabisches Land
wird leer oder nur wenige Individuen  Arabischer
Raum, das ist ein großes Potenzial, lassen Sie sie
bauen, Sie konnten bisher nicht in Ihr
Heimatland zurückkehren, wenn ich Sie darum bitte  o Machen Sie eine
Perspektive in fünfzig Jahren.
Wie glauben Sie, wird die Welt in
50 Jahren in der Zukunft sein
? Jia hatte tatsächlich 1996 die
Gelegenheit, sich mit der Königinmutter von England zu treffen,
dann ist ihre eigene 96, also hat sie fast
das ganze Jahrhundert beobachtet, wo ich sie gebeten
habe  Sie denken, die Weltmenschheit wird
besser oder gleich oder schlechter, ohne zu
zögern, sagte sie, besser, sie gibt eine
Art Beispiel ab, als sie
jung war
, sprach niemand, Menschenrecht oder
Selbstbestimmungsrecht, heutzutage werden diese
Dinge universell, es ist wahr, also
also denke ich das  Im vergangenen Jahrhundert zu
Beginn des 20. Jahrhunderts denke ich, dass die Leute, insbesondere die
Wissenschaftler, voller Enthusiasmus
Atomwaffen herstellen. Im späteren Teil des
20. Jahrhunderts
spricht jetzt noch einer,
was immer mehr Reden Sie darüber sagen, wie
diese Waffe reduziert werden kann, und ich werde sie jetzt
drei Jahre für Sie widerrufen  Sehen Sie sich den
darunter stehenden Punkt an, Obama spricht jetzt tatsächlich
Benny oder Atomwaffenfrei
von Herzen, also sind diese Zeichen
positiv und dann auch die Totalitaria  n
System ohne Waffe durch das eigene
Volk verändert serviert Union Zusammenbruch
viele osteuropäische Länder werden so ein
freies Land wie das
jetzt China nicht geht hier wenig Art
besonders ist nicht Korea, aber China auch
Sie sehen viel verändert das aus ich meine im
Allgemeinen immer noch kommunistisch und  Die gleiche
Verfassung, aber die Realität hat sich
jetzt stark verändert. Ich denke,
dies ist ein Beispiel. Das heutige China hat heute
etwa vierhundert Millionen buddhistische
Bevölkerung. Während der heutigen
Kulturrevolution wurde absichtlich jeder
Glaube zerstört. Der heutige
Buddhismus wurde jedoch sehr schnell wiederbelebt und
Der Buddhist hat seine Zahl in China, wie ich
Anfang dieses Jahres erwähnt habe, für ungefähr
vierhundert Millionen angegeben, der Christ über alles,
ich denke, weniger als 200 Meter, das sind
große Veränderungen, also können wir
positiv und optimistisch sein, wir können
optimistisch sein, ok, ich glaube, Sie sehen
Ich glaube, ich glaube, die Menschheit und
darüber hinaus in den letzten Jahren
eine Art unserer wissenschaftlichen Begegnung
Dialog Einige Wissenschaftler haben durch ihre
Untersuchung jetzt bestätigt, dass die
menschliche Natur mitfühlender ist, und
dann tun sie
leicht verständlich die ständige Angst, die
besorgt ist, dass Wut unser
Immunsystem frisst, mitfühlenderer Geist,
mehr Frieden oder dass immense Trauer hilft
, eine gute Gesundheit zu erhalten, wenn jemand
wirklich das hat  Überzeugung der Wert des
Mitgefühls, dass alle Religion
immens ist, zu sagen, um diesen inneren Wert zu stärken
, deine Heiligkeit, wir sind bereits
am Ende, und ich danke dir so sehr, dass du
dein Wissen und deine Weisheit
mit uns teilst. Vielen Dank, danke
[Musik]